foreign
[Music]
welcome to this webinar my name is Mara
Coto Rodriguez I am the director of
research and development at biosha and
today I will be talking about hybrid
capture star scoby 2 and GS assay and
covet DX a robust end-to-end solution
for viral detection and surveillance of
genetic variants so
um first of all I would like to start by
introducing myself
um so I am originally from Puerto Rico
and that's where I started my research
career
um I started working with plant microbe
interactions particularly uh the
microbial communities that were
associated with seagrasses and we were
employing in this time early metagenomic
techniques and plastic microbiology
techniques to try to identify the
microbial communities associated with
the seagrasses and so in the left hand
side you can see a picture of as Astro
microscopy
of a cross-section of the seagrass leaf
which is showing also some bacteria
growing among it
um and so after I finished this time in
Puerto Rico then I continue Graduate
Studies at the University of Georgia
while in Puerto Rico I was uh
introduced to fungi and I became really
fascinated by these types of organisms
just because they are unique in their
biology and their genetics and so I
moved on to working with the Philippines
fungus aspergillus fumigators this
fungus is an opportunistic fungus and we
were interested in looking at how some
cytoskeletal elements are important
during cell cycle regulation in
particular how they are involved in
regulating uh polar growth which is
really important when
fungi are
invading human tissues so um here in
this work I employed multiple techniques
such as
um classic genetics uh cell biology and
then also pyrosequencing uh and in the
middle you can observe just a
fluorescent microscopy picture of
looking at the fungus and how it
develops throughout all of the
developmental stages uh in green we have
labeled uh septin which is a
cytoskeletal element really important
for this transition from Polar growth uh
in filamentous fungi and then in red are
the nuclei that are labeled so after I
finish with this research then I moved
on to Columbia University
where I was working with multiple
projects in the microbiome field
um and these uh research I was employing
next Generation sequencing techniques in
order to try and
the role of the microbiome
during Health ndcs both in chronic and
acute illnesses including HIV
Silvers bacterial vaginosis colorectal
cancer and maternal antibiotic exposure
This research was not only limited to
The Human Condition we also published
the paper where we studied the gut
microbiome of gorillas from the Republic
of Congo and we were able to identify
how the microbial communities
in the gorillas shifted depending on the
diet that the gorillas were
consuming doing to their during their
seasonal fluctuations so our most recent
paper we have published was also looking
at post-infectious hydrocephalus in
Ugandan children and we were able to
identify this bacterial strainability
which was uh one of the mediators of
this hydrocephalus for Ugandan children
so with that I in 2019 I joined biosha
in order to use the skill set that I
have acquired throughout all of these
years and complement a biosha's mission
which is fighting infectious disease
with genomics Nai while building the
world's leading micro wheel sequence
database so it's no surprise that when
the pandemic hit last year
we decided to shift our focus and try to
help use our skills and the tool sets
that we have developed as a company to
try to help uh the pandemic response so
in this talk you will be hearing a bit
more about
biosha's efforts for this pandemic and
so just to line up
um our agenda for today today I'm going
to be talking about how Next Generation
sequencing is crucial for tracking viral
Evolution to support pandemic
surveillance I am also going to be going
into detail on how a hybrid capture NGS
workflow looks like and in addition I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
how a hybrid capture based NGS approach
enables more robust and reliable variant
detection
so we are a year now into the pandemic
and uh recently we have started to hear
about these uh new variants that are
emerging and uh during this time back in
December we started hearing about uh
v117 it variant that was detected in the
UK but shortly after that we also
Sciences started to
um
report uh new variants emerging in South
Africa such as Varian b1351 uh variant
in Brazil such as P1 and then also it's
not surprise no surprise that uh we have
also detected variants in the U.S
um because there has been a rampant
infection rate uh during last year
um so we've detected uh variants in New
York City
um California and so on but we do
believe that there may be other variants
that are circulating among the U.S
population that are still going
undetected
so why are these variants concerning
um these variants are concerning because
they impact our tools that we have and
that we have to detect uh the virus to
um also eradicate the virus based on
vaccines and it may also impact clinical
outcomes
um for testing
um we have observed that uh some of the
qpcr tests that are used for Diagnostics
have experienced false negative due to
the mutations that have been arising in
some of these uh
strains additionally
um it is no surprise that for as the
virus keeps mutating and accumulating
mutations some of these mutations are
going to fall within the antigenic
region that is used for vaccine
development and that can definitely
impact the efficacy of the vaccine this
has already been observed as a six-fold
reduction in neutralized in titers for
b1351 for the moderna vaccine and in
terms of clinical outcomes not only the
virus can mutate and become more
transmissible but also it can become
more virulent and then impacting
potential uh the clinical outcomes of
patients
so um what are some of the key testing
approaches that we have available at the
moment for uh Stars Kobe 2. uh the most
widely used are PCR test and these PCR
tests basically take uh the nucleic acid
and then we amplify one to three Targets
in the viral genome uh this is only for
uh the text presence absence of the
virus and within a sample and so this is
a highly scalable and Rapid test to use
uh for high volume of samples
um however there is also sequencing
based approaches that use uh that we are
able to
sequence the full viral genome and
allows us to detect changes in the
nucleotides allows us to detect new
variants that may be emerging and also
track the evolution of the virus while
also comparing viral strain among
different populations across the world
of the sequencing based approaches that
are available at the moment there are
two types uh there is shotgun sequencing
and Target enrichment sequencing if we
think about the clinical specimen in
particular clinical specimen that is
used for uh SARS kobitsu it's a
nasopharyngeal swab in a nasopharyngeal
swab this is a complex
um Matrix where you're also you're
having not only the virus of interest
that you want to detect but also you
have human cells uh and microbial cells
within the sample when you use a shotgun
sequencing you basically extract uh the
nucleic acid of that mix of cells and
then you sequence prepare the the
samples and sequence everything that is
present within the sample this means
that if you think about a virus a virus
is very small has a very small genome
and then it is kind of
um hard to find the virus be in between
the high uh background that uh there is
of human cells microbial cells and all
of that so basically you're trying to
find a needle in a haystack
um this will require a higher sequencing
than it there it has decreased
sensitivity due to the presence of human
uh nucleic acids and microbial nucleic
acid another if you think about then uh
targeted uh enrichment approach
basically what you're doing is trying to
uh take out first all of those viral
sequences by using by amplifying the
Target using uh probes or primers that
would Target uh SARS cov2 in that case
you're amplifying that signal then it
would require less step of sequencing it
would provide greater coverage and would
allow for variant detection this is also
less costly and much more sensitive than
a shotgun sequencing approach
of the targeted
um sequencing approaches uh there are
two types there is amplicon base and the
most widely used at the moment is Arctic
uh and in this uh type of approach
basically there is pools of primers that
Target uh the SARS Kobe 2 genome
um and tile across the viral genome and
then after amplifying the signal then
the sample is sequenced
the hybridization capture-based approach
uses a different uh technology and in
this case it uses probes that are biotin
labeled and these probes kind of pull
out or fish out uh the viral sequences
and then the the signal is Amplified and
this has been proven to be more suited
for detecting variants but is definitely
a slower
um
workflow
so in as I said uh by OSHA we have
shifted our attention to uh helping
combat uh the pandemic and with that we
partner with twist biosciences uh and an
agile team we responded to the pandemic
and within four months we were able to
uh optimize The Twist Stars Kobe 2
um assay we validated it on clinical
nasopharyngeal samples built a
cloud-based uh software and also
co-submitted this technology to the FDA
we were able to launch our
um platform as a research used version
uh back in November 2020 and at the
moment this assay is being used across
Europe and U.S labs to help track and
surveil genetic variants uh most
recently we finally received uh eua
approval for the hybrid capture base NGS
FDA eua test
um and this has both a diagnostic and
research application within our solution
we're able to provide deep insights
genetic variants and it's also coupled
with a user portal that is connected to
a lymph system that automatically
reports um to New York State
so how does this uh workflow looks like
so we have provided an end-to-end
solution from receiving of a specimen
down to translating it into a clinical
report we start as I said we have
validated our assay in nasopharyngeal
specimens so we've received
nasopharyngeal specimens in transport
media those nasopharyngeal specimens
undergo nucleic acid extraction using
the cymodorexial DNA and RNA mini prep
kit after that RNA is converted to cdna
using NAB enzymes followed by Library
preparation of trusic compatible
libraries using the twist Library
preparation kit following the library
preparation then the target enrichment
occurs using twist Stars cov2 pro panel
and finally the pools are loaded into a
nexig 550 from Illumina after the
sequencer finishes then these fastq
files are uploaded through the user
portal
um by oceans user portal and then this
user portal would take the genetic
information uh it will uh compare it to
a database that we have uh built and
then will generate a report that is very
user friendly and in this report we're
able to report variants that are
detected we give a viral plate
estimation and phylogenetic tree uh with
a background of over 3 000 sequences
that we were we pulled from uh GSAT
we look in more carefully into what the
wet lab component of this workflow looks
like it contains five modules uh the
first module begins with the nucleic
acid extraction after extraction of the
nucleic acid then it is converted to
cdna uh first Strand and second strand
synthesis after cdna generation
then we move on on to library
preparation our library preparation
undergoes ensematic fragmentation
followed by adapter ligation and then
barcoding of the libraries
um this will allow us to run 96 samples
at a time
um and then after the cdna library
generation then the samples go uh
through the capture in which we are
enriching four stars cov2 sequences uh
these samples are pulled in apexes uh
and from apexes then there is
hybridization to the probes filed by a
post-captured PCR amplification and
finally uh libraries are loaded into the
next week 550.
so we uh as I said we have validated our
result on laser pharyngeal specimens and
now I'm just going to talk a little bit
about the performance of our assay and
also other results that are associated
to our asset so uh first of all uh we
compared our assay to an RT PCR and our
assay uh yielded 96.7 positive percent
agreement and 100 negative agreements uh
to the rtpcr in addition we established
a limit of detection of 800 copies per
ml which is 0.8 copies per microliter
this is a little bit uh more sensitive
than other sequencing based assays that
are in the Market at the moment uh
within our report as I mentioned we are
able to also covariance on uh samples
and this is in the bottom is an example
of um
one of the figures that are is generated
in our report uh you can observe the
structure of the SARS cov2 genome uh in
the top panel uh we report the coverage
of the sample including the variants
that were detected uh within the sample
in this case the uh the sample contained
five uh six variants and um in in the
bottom panel of it then it's this
comparison against the database that we
have built and then it also shows the
frequencies of these variants detected
within the samples when compared to the
global database
additionally we wanted to understand the
performance of our assay compared to uh
the gold standard which is RT PCR
and we used uh we we took our data and
broke it down
and CT values categories uh from 15 to
20 20 to 25 25 to 30 and 3235
um and we were able to detect an average
fold enrichment of the virus of 50 000 X
for all the samples within our clinical
validation we detected a 93 coverage at
5x across the genome with 99 coverage in
48 out of the 60 samples within the
clinical validation uh when we looked at
the depth of coverage uh our percent of
coverage of the genome at different
depths we are able to see that any CT
value below 30 gives really good
enrichment uh of the viral sequences and
allows us to have very good coverage uh
to confidently call variants of all
samples even looking at a depth of 100x
we're still getting at the higher range
of 25 to 30 a very good coverage percent
coverage of the genome
so
We additionally uh took these samples
along with a small subset of samples
from Tennessee
um and these samples were analyzed
against the global database uh for stars
Kobe 2 and we were able to detect a
total of 730 mutations within 71 samples
that we tested and these mutations were
located at 258 different mutation sites
of these are 107 mutations were new
mutations that were not previously
reported in GSAT and 24 of these
mutations were located in the clinically
relevant Spike protein uh the most
frequently detected variants within the
sample set were
c241t which is an extragenic mutation
and and then uh d614g mutation in the
spike protein this is one of the most
prevalent mutations among stars cov2
samples since late spring
so We additionally as I said we use
samples from two different Geographic
locations New York City and Tennessee
and these share similar genetic
mutations uh and in the picture and on
the right uh you can see on the top
panel uh the SARS Kobe 2 genome and all
of the 71 samples that we have uh
analyzed these were aligned against the
Wuhan reference train and we looked into
what were the mutations that were
present uh among all samples uh in
purple it is uh denoted the all of the
new mutations that we found within our
clinical validation study uh on the top
panel you can also see the percent of
samples that contain uh this those
mutations so basically we had some a
handful of predominant mutations of
those as I mentioned and we had
um
d614g was detected within our cohort on
what's what one of the most prevalent uh
mutations within our samples
Additionally the majority of the noble
variants that are denoted in purple are
located at the orf-1ab Gene and 24 of
those novel variants were detected in
the spike protein we also detected 14
frameships after synonymous mutations
and two of those frame shifts were
detected in the spike protein we
identified unique mutation specific for
the geographic location particularly for
Tennessee samples we were able to detect
a mutation in the orf-1ab region which
is mutation
t6394c and we also took some of these
new mutations that we detected and were
able to validate them with a another
sequencing based approach which was
angular sequencing this just confirmed
that our technology is quite robust at
detecting variants and then also it
allows us to confidently
um
call all of these uh new mutations uh
that have been found
so
additionally within uh our assay we are
able to uh study the microbiome and uh
this is because the extraction kits that
were used on our validation and that is
now established in our workflow
um allows for DNA separate DNA
extraction and uh so with this in mind
and because we
biome at biosha we were very interested
in looking and profiling uh how the
nasopharyngeal microbiome looks like in
patients that have uh that are positive
for stars cov2 and patients that are
negative for Star scope E2 so
uh we were able to uh profile the
microbiome in 48 nasopharyngeal swamps
we had to exclude some samples uh within
our cohort because most of these samples
yielded uh very high human background
and there was no undetectable microbiome
um however in this figure uh right here
you can observe a heat map that is
denoting the relative abundance of the
top 50 most abundant bacterial species
um these are bacterial species are
um were not the microbiome profiles were
not uh separating depending on cobit
status uh however we were able to use
other metagenomic tools to determine uh
biomarkers within our samples and we
found an over-representation of six
different taxa including prevotella
within covet positive uh samples
with uh this uh metagenomic approach we
are also able to profile in AMR genes
and viruses that are present in the
specimens we are particularly interested
in AMR genes given that many patients
are being over prescribed antibiotics
during this time of covet and we need to
be very Mindful and in monitoring AMR
resistance genes that may be emerging
due to the over prescription uh of
antibiotics to covet patients many of
these patients undergo co-infections and
so it is quite crucial to also address
the AMR profiles within uh covet
patients we detected on an
anti-microbial resistance Gene called
Mel C this one was overrepresented in uh
covet positive specimens and also we
were able to detect some DNA viruses
including
um influenza A and purpose fire is for
so uh in summary our uh approach we're
able to also profile the the native
pharyngeal microbiome and again some
insights on whether there are some uh of
these microbial communities that may be
modulating the immune system or also
maybe important uh uh for co-infections
on SARS Kobe 2 patients so it is quite a
great tool for any researcher that would
want to look into the microbiome
um so with that then I would like to
summarize uh the importance of hybrid
capture for viral surveillance so our
hybrid capture approach has the ability
to tolerate more mismatches about ten to
three percent due to the usage of 120
base pairs double-stranded DNA probe
this allows for a more efficient capture
of the target it enables more robust
variant detection as the virus continues
to evolve these mismatches allows us to
keep discovering these uh new uh
variants which is a limitation of some
of the amplicon-based sequencing
approaches that are available right now
they these uh use primers of 20 to 30
base pairs in lens which also could
hinder uh the any mismatches could
hinder the ability of the primer to bind
and then we would experience dropouts
and missing some of these variants an
example of this is also observed in rtq
PCR test some of the rtq PCR tests that
are available in the market targeted the
spike protein um and these uh region has
experienced a significant amount of
mutations in particular for the b117
strain uh detected originally in the UK
and this has yielded into increased
false negative results for some of these
tests so uh what if the next steps for
Our Stars Kobe 2 assay
um we want to expand to different sample
types we have already tested some uh
other sample types including saliva with
in in collaboration with other
researchers we are interested also in
expanding into a more comprehensive
respiratory panel that perhaps would
allow us to identify influenza and stars
cov2
and we also want to uh have efforts to
support automation to increase through
put up samples uh for either research
Labs or clinical Labs so
um and what's the future
um for biosha so
biosha we are interested in uh looking
forward in enabling personalized
data-driven pathogen Discovery and
diagnostics from the individual to the
community
um building Precision infectious disease
Diagnostics and NGS guided patient
treatment uh that would lead us to build
uh leading database database for
Predictive Analytics uh to protect
communities and also ultimately we want
to be able to detect any pathogen from
any sample type or any type of domain
allowing us to move forward uh on
eradicating death due to anxious
diseases and so with that I would like
to close just acknowledging our amazing
team at biosha these uh we have all
worked very hard on the past year to
develop this solution and bringing it to
researchers and clinical diagnostic labs
and that will also like to thank
um our collaborators at twist uh which
we developed test with in particular
Kristen butchers to juanchen Brian
Hoagland Shaquille and Peter are
collaborators in the University of
Tennessee Dr Colleen Johnson and Mariah
Taylor Robert Burstein at lanco
laboratory for providing clinical
samples both for validation and any
other follow-up work Agnes Berkey she's
a consultant uh to biosha and then also
ayabi Sunni downstairs and bio bad
um so with that I would like to then say
thank you for watching this webinar and
if you have any questions or would like
to know more about our asset please feel
free to reach out uh to my email or to
any of the social media um
platforms thank you